PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Who
doesn't love saving money?
Stay tuned to learn the
secrets of cost optimization
with Anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Priyanka, and
welcome to Anthos 101.
In the next five
minutes, we're going
to cover five ways to reduce
your costs using Anthos.
So let's jump into
the five in five.
Number one,
improving visibility.
Imagine you have
an application that
was built on premises years ago
but has highly variable usage.
How awesome it
would be to move it
to the cloud to take
advantage of auto-scaling,
so you can pay for
resources when you need them
and not all the time?
On the other hand,
imagine you have
an app that is running
in the cloud and that
has pretty consistent
traffic patterns,
and you happen to have
capacity on premises.
Why not move it there and
leverage your existing
investments?
Now, we know that Anthos
provides consistency
and portability across hybrid
and multi-cloud environments,
which allows you to see all of
the resources you're consuming
and easily balance and
re-balance them across those
environments, which means--
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Number two,
reducing operational overhead.
Now, imagine your
platform operations team,
which is responsible for
configuring, patching,
and releasing, not to mention
sometimes migration from one
environment to another.
It is a huge overhead
to do all that
across clouds and on premises.
With Anthos, you get
a single pane of glass
for management and
configuration of resources,
which improves productivity.
Similarly, your security
team that creates, deploys,
and enforces security policies
across your application
development life
cycles, with Anthos,
you get to consistently apply
security policies across all
your applications,
spanning cloud and on-prem,
which means--
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: With
the efficiencies gained,
your teams can
focus their energy
on building great applications.
Number three, modernizing
monolithic apps.
Every organization has at least
a few monolithic applications
that are costly to
scale and manage.
While Google Cloud
supports common management
of virtual machines
and containers,
I'm sure you're already looking
to the future of breaking down
your monolithic applications
into container-based
micro-services to
scale and manage
your resources efficiently.
Using Migrate for Anthos,
you can turn your VMs
into container-based apps
without having to re-architect
or re-platform manually.
This helps you
simplify operations,
such as dynamic scaling, and
integrate with other Anthos
services, like service mesh,
for better resource monitoring.
And by containerizing
your app, you're
able to pack more resources on
less infrastructure, leading
to--
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Number four, removing
the need for hypervisor.
If you're running Kubernetes
applications on prem,
you may begin to assess the need
for third-party hypervisors.
So we announced that later in
2020 you will be able to run
Anthos with no
third-party hypervisors,
further eliminating the
management overhead of yet
another vendor
relationship and reducing--
SPEAKER: Costs.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Number
five, optimization tools
available in Google
Cloud Marketplace.
If you're already running
Kubernetes and looking
to optimize costs, check out
Google Cloud Marketplace,
which offers solutions
from commercial partners
and open source projects that
take innovative approaches
to monitor and
report on resources
running within your clusters.
These Kubernetes applications
are pre-integrated with Anthos
and deploy quickly, saving you--
well, saving you
time, which saves--
SPEAKER: Costs.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Often, circumstances
beyond our control
force changes in budgets
and send us into a
cost-saving mode.
As you assess the benefits
of adopting Anthos,
consider the cost
optimizations you
can realize with
improved operations,
consistent monitoring,
modernization, bare metal,
and partner technologies.
Ready to get started?
Connect with a partner
or your sales team
to do an assessment
of your current hybrid
and multi-cloud strategy.
And read the total
economic impact study
at cloud.google.com/anthos.
For more Anthos
content, don't forget
to subscribe, and follow
the Anthos 101 playlist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]